[Music]
you shall rest from life like the
Setting Sun in the West but you shot on
a new in the East as the first phrase of
a man robbed dispelled the shutter
[Music]
I totally from this time period appear
to stop what the hell you guys doing
well you told us to dress up as the
original mummy movie yeah 1932 Boris
Karloff everybody knows that the
original mummy is the brendan fraiser
version why are you dressed up as
grunkle Stan and talking like a Franken
berry oh my god I am so sick of people
saying this the Brendan Fraser one is
not the original sure it is that's why
when the crappy remake came out everyone
said is not as good as the original yeah
isn't that true no I mean yes I mean it
is a sin against nature and this is that
original film no this was the first
crappy remake you didn't like it I
didn't say that I said it was crappy
what was meant to be crappy at least
afraid of God it was let's just all come
together and agree that the Tom Cruise
one sucks yes I mean I mean I want to
show people what a great mummy movie was
supposed to be he's at the Tom Cruise
one was great there's more than two
movies well people remember the Frasier
one you should talk about that but I'll
leave it to the audience how many of you
a guy hurts wives told ya a piss off
Tommy and Aragon joke
sad to say that in recent years when
many people refer to the original mummy
movie this is the one they're talking
about the 1999 had quickly established
it had as much to do with the original
mummy as say The Last Airbender had to
do with the original avatar except a
little less penis hitter nevertheless it
found its audience not as a horror film
but rather a corny light-hearted
adventure it spawned sequels spin-offs
even a children's cartoon and let me
tell you it is no Jackie Chan adventures
so after years of popularity and yes
even future remakes taking more from
this than the original source material
those makes sense to see if this still
holds up or if honestly it was ever
really meant to hold up let's take a
look at 1999 the original shut up you
watch something black and white The
Mummy it starts off in
[Music]
oh I'm sorry I apparently put out an
episode of the cartoon Oh
ee sorry these are apparently really
convincing effects not to knock what is
admittedly pretty CG but Val Kilmer
refines as moses and rama sees fit a
little too well into this realistic
backdrop these round jewel of pharaoh
seti the first home of emotive pharaohs
high priest keeper of the dead who
enjoys sitting really close to the
screen playing Assassin's Creed origins
no again I mean looking over realistic
Egypt look at the film credit that has
fake as everything looks it is still a
gorgeous and artistically pleasing body
of work and the CGI ain't bad either
Imhotep has an affair with the pharaoh's
mistress which seems to be done then the
more I think about it but the gold
investors are unable to block hock for a
long yeah Tommy cotton
[Music]
I had an itch what Egyptians never have
an itch or you can kill him at work what
the mistress has a plan for the guards
who came to arrest her ha ha show them
he motive plans to resurrect her though
as wait I can't not play this this is
all a cartoon
don't believe me look at the effects
when trying to bring his love back to
life oh my God we're in the remake of
the haunting destroy everything except
your by Katherine Tina Jones's a dream
Dale's attached to a giant bomb with Tom
Cruise
Imhotep has to kill her to resurrect her
but he stops and mummified covered in CG
bugs will also give him apparently the
worst of all curses the Magi would never
allow him to be released for he would
arise a walking disease power over the
sands and the glory of invincibility
kind of a dumb curse when you think
about it oh yes you will suffer for
years and years and if by chance
somebody saves you you'll become the
most powerful and invincible entity
known to man were there no other curses
that left that part out with that curse
on sale and for 3,000 years
we the Magi the descendants of Pharaohs
sacred bodyguards kept watch geez these
guys have the laziness of the Crucified
sort of written all over them if you did
your job well we wouldn't have a movie
you'd come across a desert battle and
meet our main character Rick played by
Frasier and as comic relief Benny
don't worry he'll be back soon to
confuse charming side antagonist with
shot soon enough
thank God they set the rifles to a round
target instead of on target a spooky
face in the ground scares everyone away
including Frazer banish him to monkey
bone meanwhile rachel weisz plays a
librarian named Evelyn who's searching
in the S section for suck ass comedy
it's funny because nope well give him a
point that they actually knocked all
these bookcases over in one shot with no
CG involved it almost excuses the
lame-ass exposition we have to sit
through why do I put up with you don't
with me because I can I can read and
write ancient Egyptian and I can I can
decipher hieroglyphics and hieratic
I force plot points with no natural
rhyme or rhythm she thinks she hears a
noise so she grabs one of those
necessary torches kept around ancient
artifacts I guess electricity wasn't a
common thing yet oh wait where she's led
to her piss-poor fake-out yeah
messing with priceless corpses in Egypt
best-case scenario fired worst-case
scenario death this is Jonathan Weiss
his brother who just happened to find
the Hellraiser box which contains a map
to Egyptian tombs and treasure this
looks like a job for pervy George of the
jungle who are you yeah who's the broad
was there your sweat every damn day
Eddie's place my slightly dirty skin and
perfect white teeth already for rugged
adventure so yeah brendan fraiser sticks
out like a member of scrubs in an
Indiana Jones movie
but given the film's goofy tone you
could argue that's the point it is a
silly environment so his mismatched
voice and look doesn't go unwelcome then
chutneys eye hell out of here my problem
is there would have been so many other
non matching actors
would have been even cooler team agile
bruce campbell in that role it make no
sense but they'd be awesome who are you
and who's the bride get me the hell out
of here and by God tell me why they're
guys in that hamster wheel it's not even
attached to anything
sadly though Frasier is said to hang his
neck doesn't break which allows Weis
time to bargain for his life telling his
captor that if he releases him she'll
lead them to the treasure he agrees not
realizing force romantic interludes or a
shitty-ass Lucas wipe away the ruse
completely well I didn't like you one
bit know what I know oh my horny MS
totally forgot what I was saying my
whole damn garrison believed in this so
much and without orders they marched
halfway across Libya and into Egypt to
find that City and when we got there all
we found was sand and blood like it
totally put me off my surfing lessons
I'm a rogue one of the most famous books
in history is buried out there the book
of amun-ra and the fact that they say
that it's made out of pure gold makes no
nevermind - you write those thinking of
dyeing my hair gold would that be cool
I'm a lowlife why did you kiss me I was
about to be hanged it seemed like a good
idea at the time
I thought we had something man I've
known for less than a day what they sail
on a ship discovering that another troop
happens to be looking for the exact same
thing on the exact same ship they even
come across the exact same where we
coming for Leif you're alive Bartok the
bat they pay me only half now half when
I get them back the Cairo's how am I
supposed to believe that they woke up
after all these years you never believed
in humming ups row come oh sure blame
the bath what the heck we're easy
targets
a minute you are not gonna unhear this
but a universal stunt show breaks out
and everybody is forced to abandon the
ship they managed to come across some
camels and surprisingly they don't focus
on their flatulence you missed a
cinematic diamond mine and they traveled
to the ruins using day for night and
dumb for smart
doing patience my good Verizon patient
you know sir really you should watch
your blood pressure stress it's a killer
sir we're about to be shown the way
you sure it's not just playing a
DuckTales cartoon my god these are facts
can you believe I'm an opera here we go
again d'oeuvre so they make it to the
city and start looking for riches film
was used to shoot that rope scene I
think we all acknowledge it was worth it
they journey inward to see what they can
find they ripped out your guts and they
stuffed them in jars and then they take
out your heart as well
now are they just mystic damnit and find
the book of the dead Fraser's captor
however finds one of the deadly bugs
concealed in a Cadbury egg that somehow
survived all these years despite being
in a Cadbury egg
oh no I mean Photoshop to death Christ
it's Macaulay Culkin the mattoon with
him
[Applause]
he died as he lived like curly Howard
Tresa find more I'd show up a day late
you proving they suck at what they do
and making them even more done when they
just tell them to leave and then they
leave leave leave this place on a time
oh those are our choices huh hey you
notice how their backs are to us right
now
of course having half your crew killed
and your life threatened doesn't mean
you can't get smashed the exact same
night I know when to say no and then
like your brother missed you I just
don't get I am going to kiss you call me
Rick Kurt Russell that would have been a
weird but badass choice I could totally
see him in that role call me Rick and
for God's sakes grow your eyebrows back
what are you doing
[Music]
Wow I'd say never on a first date but
this never happens on the first date
okay
that's the one thing brendan fraiser
could add that nobody else could add
this whole entire performance might be
worth it just for that one reaction
you hold on to that Frasier let no one
take that from you but they discover emo
tips corpse and are surprised to find
he's still decomposing after all these
years perhaps it has something to do
with the remains of the bugs in his tomb
they can stay alive for years feasting
on the flesh of course
so somebody threw these in with our guy
and then they slowly ate him alive very
slowly
yes as we already saw they really take
their time there they're like
flesh-eating snails the other guys find
ancient soap dispensers unaware that
they hold some of emo tips vital organs
doesn't make him happy though when he
wakes up after doofen doofus read the
passage that resurrects him from the
Book of the Dead see how much cooler
that would be this unleashes a plague of
a caste locusts sadly not led by James
Earl Jones all hell starts to break
loose is even more of those bugs are
released still eating people super
slowly as you can see very slowly you
know has anyone consider she has no idea
what she's talking about thus only an
hour in we finally get our mummy and
pretty sure legends of the Hidden Temple
would have done it better yeah it's
pretty bad I mean given the time period
it's pretty bad okay
now we're trying to do a troll face if
it was on a tree from The Wizard of Oz
what do it
Frasier saves her by blasting his emo
dick justify bucks block them off told
you to leave up dye it if used now you
may have killed us all
you know I love the way this guy says
everything no matter what he's talking
about I feel like it should always be
followed by man or you know I told you
to leave or die and it refused you know
now you may have killed a soul man relax
I got it no mortal weapon can kill this
creature you know he's not of this world
man but Imhotep comes across Benny who
quit musingly prays to every religion
where are you just keeping those in your
pelvic bone you have no skin you have no
clothes there's nowhere else you could
keep it this really needs an answer
despite how much I don't want it
[Applause]
[Music]
you
so Fraser suggest they leave why suggest
they stay and the rest of us debate if
this sounds more like Will and Grace are
mad about you I told you not to play
around didn't I tell you not to play
around you heard the man no mortal
weapons can kill this guy twice at this
point I take Archer in this roles look
you can either tag along with me or stay
here and try to save the world do you
want mummies cuz this is how you get
mommies Frasier goes to the bar to get
hammered we're an ex-pilot talks about
his woes about there being no adventures
anymore
I'm sure absolutely nothing in the near
future will tie into this Chuck jizeen
with the others and gun down and flame
and glory instead of sitting around here
rotting of boredom yes chairman mao's
from the rescue where movies oh it
actually is it random The Mummy and
Benny locate one of the people who took
the sacred jars
I'm afraid more is needed oh the prince
will finish the job and consummates the
curse I guess a curse just ain't what it
used to be hot fur side no bells very
nice you two fill me in before you kill
me I mean I know you got a lot on your
plate right now in time is probably of
the essence I was very considerate of
you to do
we are in serious trouble you know I
should probably count how many times a
good one lion areas instead of replaced
by Brendan Fraser making a stupid face
and stating the obvious
[Music]
very serious
the mummy moves in on Weis but gets
pussy with being afraid of cats who are
revealed to be the guardians of the
underworld Weiss's boss was in cahoots
with the Crucified dorks and helped him
in their terrible job of protecting the
world apparently even after 3,000 years
man once again but I could raise her
from the dead you know and he stretched
forth his hand towards the heavens no
yeah because that brother character is
entirely useless they tried to justify
him by having him quote the Bible every
time something plaguey happens and the
rivers and waters of Egypt ran red as
blood oh shut up VeggieTales you're
still pointless so Fraser decides to
lock whites in her room leave the other
rogues to look after her and bring the
brother with him to find Imhotep she
doesn't come out and no one goes in
right right
let's go Jonathan Wow every single one
of those choices was wrong
she knows the most about the mummy so
she should go along they're more
qualified to fight so they should go
along and he I refer you back to useless
does anyone know how to do their job in
this movie I guess he didn't want a
repeat of what happened him running into
Benny the mummy killing another
scrounger putting the moves on Weiss a
plague happening and being scared by a
cat so what happens he runs into Fenny
The Mummy kills another scrounger puts
the moves on Weiss a plank happens and
he scared by a cat well just come
through so huh yeah with the exception
of the explanation with Weiss's boss
which even then I feel like we could
have figured out the past eight minutes
are just a repeat and totally should
have been deleted but at least two more
souls are sucked dry which means the
mummy must look at least a little more
realistic now
as realistic as a cartoon mouth upon
your phone is this about me meant to be
scary or adorable I'm gonna say ask
arable imhotep hypnotizes an army and
forces them to go after our heroes
faster patience is a virtue not right
now it is a derp face get through the
back but the mummy has an extra trick up
his sleeve
okay glad you got that out you system
the army eventually corners them as the
fully regenerated Imhotep approaches and
if Weiss is anything like she was
earlier she's probably like woohoo
that's what he looks like I'll put
together
good dog me follow us whatever he's
asking yes the city I convinced me my
princess take my hand and I bear your
friends is this the face of a bath who
would lie to you she decides to go with
him under the condition that he spares
her friends he agrees to disagree
it was the noble stupid thing to do her
boss sacrifices himself so the rescue an
escape and they go to Chairman Mao's for
the use of his plane what's the
challenge then rescue the damsel in
distress kill the bad guy and save the
world
yeah one of these bullshit's movies
right home ten travels be a warp whistle
and I gotta say for being in the sand
star they look pretty damn good but mr.
Sandman isn't done yet my god
this must be Anakin Skywalker's worst
nightmare I don't like sand he swallows
the plane up though I guess not too deep
seeing how there's still plenty of blue
sky in sight but Weiss has an idea
Oh God now the storms Tungus attacking
us what's going on well it appears to
not be enough
I love the whole sand wall trick it was
beautiful bastard you don't need to
impress me Morty sadly the only
character I sympathize with the drunk
who just wants to die gets killed but if
we're lucky maybe we can go for two yes
very smugly eat him alive very slowly
sadly he's saved but Imhotep hears them
and sends his biggest threat yet mummies
they're actually there oh my god they're
actually right in front of us I mean
really right there it's not Jar Jar chef
rod
oh whoops don't worry we still got the
fake shit over here
yet surprisingly playing the exact same
effect doesn't make it look any more
real it still looks like a Smurfs needs
to milk for his nose The Mummy of emo
tips bride comes to life though but
before you can make the human sacrifice
Frasier saved the day they forgot to
subtitle that scene so I'll just throw
my own in for creature as powerful as a
god
Imhotep doesn't really do that much
outside of just watching them fight and
go thank God I'm not the butt ugly CGI
rock in the shittiest sequel and when he
does finally fight he just utilizes more
Mario Paint effects you know call me
crazy but dropping your jaw like the
Patrick the starfish meme doesn't seem
particularly scary look at that did the
genie lend you some acting advice or
something this was meant to be a Disney
film right but Weiss reads one last
passage that takes away his
invincibility making him mortal
[Music]
[Applause]
of course everything starts falling
apart and Benny is left behind in the
treasure room hello we'll be your
comeuppance for the evening this can
only end in tears at least you'll very
slowly eat me but don't ask told you
that very slowly
one temples run I care more about you
than any of the main characters
I'm only kissing you cuz I think I'm
gonna get hanged later how about you
darling well it's no camel fart but his
entire character is close enough so that
was the remake not the original of the
money does it hold up no but I don't
think that was really the point it's
kind of like a high budget b-movie
self-aware silly and over-the-top some
would say the bigger budget makes it
less of a b-movie but look at these
effects they look like the effects of
today's B movies so I feel like it still
kind of qualifies on top of that it is
still visually pleasant and fairly
imaginative and I think for a silly
little waste of time it's fine
it's in no way comparable to the
original but I think even the makers of
the film knew that it wasn't going to be
the best way I can put it is enjoyably
David right now we're gonna talk about
The Mummy film that's worth talking
about
you said it critic what are you doing I
want to help you talk about the mummy
movie that's worth talking about
oh of course with your love of monster
movies it only makes sense that you want
to talk about the 2017 Tom Cruise
version out of your mind
no but the movie is it's one of the most
dumbass reboots ever and we need to talk
about it yeah but what about the
original mummy
you mean the 1932 classic with Boris
Karloff and the Karras series starring
Lon Chaney jr. or the 1959 hammer
version with Christopher Lee you mean
the good ones I already talked about
them on cinemassacre here's the link
your channel on my channel look
everything about the classic versions
has already been said they're
masterpieces but this new one we need to
give it what it deserves oh so we're
really ending the style we like this
what will it still even be October by
the time this comes out it doesn't
matter to defend the honor of the
classic mummies we have to do this fine
all right
next week we'll review one of this
year's biggest nostalgic cash grabs
resulting in one of this year's biggest
bombs Oh
death is but the doorway to new life
live today
he said live again in many new forms
[Music]
[Applause]
Jojo Palooza bow
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out once again if you've been
watching the news you're probably aware
of the fires going on in California but
rather than me talk about it one of our
producers who lives out in California
been at this age is going to tell you
all about it and what you can do to help
on October 8th 2017 the city of Santa
Rosa experienced unprecedented
destruction a wildfire which has heads
been titled the Tubbs fire had rapidly
formed fueled by large amounts of dry
vegetation due to years of drought and
gusts of wind that reached hurricane
level speeds the havoc at rhod left over
5,000 buildings destroyed five percent
of the total housing area of Santa Rosa
with over a billion dollars in total
damages this combined with the
staggering casualty total of 22 lives
lost makes the Tubbs fire the most
destructive in California history as of
October 19th
the Tubbs fire has been 90% contained
but the after-effects of this disaster
will be felt for years to come but in
times of devastation the human capacity
for kindness and generosity will always
shine through and I'm here to ask for
that same light to help my city recover
right now a donation page has been set
up by the chief financial officer of
Santa Rosa to help those that have been
affected by the Tubbs fire and I urge
everyone who sees this video to donate
what they can to help those that have
lost everything to a chance and cruel
moment of chaos click on the link in the
description to donate or go to you
caring comm and search for Tubbs fire
victims please also share this video on
social media to help this Culver aid
with your help Santa Rosa can rise again
thank you
you